it's not the murder weapon but this
hidden knife stashed for future use is a
grim symbol of escalating violence
that's claimed another young life it was
a hundred yards from the site of the
latest teenage killing the fifth fatal
stabbing in a week of south london
horror a boy of 16 found dying on the
estate on bonfire night according to one
witness the victim's parents were with
him when he died we people with children
mothers we always worried when our
children are on the street we don't know
what might happen all the time I keep on
thinking about if my young one is going
outside there I keep on telling them be
careful be careful because the knife is
constantly on the street campaigner
Patrick Green believes drugs and gangs
are significant drivers of knife crime
but not the only factors we've got to
look at all the circumstances about that
which affect young people and some of it
starts in sort of aspirations for young
people who feel that they have they
can't see themselves in our society they
can see themselves building a career and
building a future it's really easy to
become a drug dealer in fact you don't
have to do very much the drug dealers
will find you I mean you do far more to
tackle those root causes give young
people hope get them into proper
employment that's where we start
london's mayor Sadiq Khan insisted this
week that to rid the capital of its
current knife crime epidemic could take
ten years nonsense said Loraine Jones
whose son Dwayne was stabbed and killed
defending a friend let's make it very
simple
if a child is living in an environment
at home where there is disrepair it's
affecting their mental and emotional
health that is gonna affect them they
won't be comfortable they won't be able
to concentrate at school it's gonna
cause some form of disturbance I'm
bringing it down to the very basic of
things that need to be addressed which
are not the root of these
young people going into gangs is for a
better life police appealed for
witnesses to the latest knife murder a
friend of the victim described him as
bubbly friendly respectful he had
manners Marty brunt Sky News South
London